former Conservative leader in Duncan
Smith is here it is very good to see you
sir how are you and you know you well
look this is a mess isn't it we're now
in a complete and utter mess well we
don't know if we're coming or going
Parliament's being probed no one seems
happy what is anyone at home meant to
make of this well actually it is a mess
I completely agree with you and I think
the biggest problem we've had is that
we've had a government that has my
government has allowed this to meander
the previous unit resumes government for
really getting off for three years the
British people voted to leave and let me
just take head-on those ridiculous
charges they didn't vote to leave
without a deer or anything else the
truth is I was one of the prominent
figures in the campaign I can tell you
categorically it was quite clear Prime
Minister then David Cameron and George
Osborne who led the remain campaign said
categorically when you leave you won't
be in the single market the customs
union you'll have to be out completely
out so the whole point about this is
really that people voted to leave can't
read into their heads what they voted
for and Boris Johnson now is a breath of
fresh air frankly he's come in and said
look we have one purpose in life which
is deliver what people voted for which
is to leave get on with it get the job
done and then have we hope a good
relationship with the European Union but
if we don't tell them and believe that
we will leave without a deal if
necessary as by the way article 50 is
explicitly says you leave on the set
date doesn't say anything about having a
deal and that's the end of it you know
if you couldn't be nice and frankly this
morning let's talk the probation is a
Ben Wallace was right was he when he was
when he was caught off mic this isn't
actually about setting a domestic agenda
is it it's about trying to to stop
Parliament blocking No Deal no I listen
to what Ben Wallace said I thought what
he was saying is there lots of other
issues around but I don't think have any
particular problem with it it's just
deal with this Pro regression issue
first of all there's a lot of crocodile
tears and totally faux shock and horror
about this the reality is for John major
just out of interest who wants to go to
court
I don't recall he went to court when he
prorogued the house to stop there being
any cash for questions issues you know
politicians are very good at forgetting
what they used to do and remembering
only what they want to so the reality is
prorogation is not some ancient idea it
happens all the time it normally happens
every single year only we've had the
longest Parliament ever for 400 years we
should have had a Queen's speech well
over two years ago but we didn't and we
haven't had one a year ago we need one
now Boris Johnson's just been elected
leader he's right and there's always
been a conference season I don't recall
labour getting up by the way in the
summer and saying we're going to cancel
our conference we want to be in the
house they didn't say that because they
want their conference and the Liberal
Democrats didn't say we're going to
cancel our conference so they were all
happy to go to the conference which they
normally would do this amounts to six
parliamentary working days in which we
are prorogued let's get this in
perspective and all those people
marching yesterday have either
completely got it wrong because somebody
told them something which is untrue or
most of them as I believe were actually
engineered by the hard left of labour
because look at the placards they were
sort of get rid of Boreas hang Boris
there's some really foul commentary
going on on social media as well so this
is very engineered by the hard left
which Tom MacDonald you saw earlier
despite the casual looking nature of his
interview is however deeply sinister and
part of that ghastly momentum crowd who
just threatened everybody there is an
argument that says you know trying to if
you stop a No Deal it stops a good
negotiation you've made that argument to
me I think would you actually want a
deal would you really want a deal I mean
I know you you backed the Brady
amendment when that was a B but you have
changed your position somewhat since
then haven't you no what happened was
very simply I don't like the word Rural
agreement I think it's a bad deal I
think we started to negotiate on bended
knee and I think by the end of it we
ended up on all fours and I have to tell
you that's no way to run a negotiation
why because we gave the EU everything
they wanted literally back in December
2017 I went to see the Prime Minister
directly and say don't sign this
Agreement you've given them their money
you've given them their continuing
period of another two to three years
locked under their rules and also the
likelihood we might
up in the customs union plus all the
other bits about defense so I said don't
sign this I was against the withdrawal
agreement any reason I finally voted at
the end was that I feared what was going
to happen next and it has happened an
uproar from the public over the fact we
didn't leave on March the 29th and now
all this chaos so the answer is get on
and do it and the reality for us is this
room doesn't fly boris has said that
everybody agrees it it has to have
fundamental changes he's already
proposed that the EU has to step up to
the plate now here's a very interesting
point right now they're not blinking why
are they not blinking because they hope
that the what they would privately think
are the dupes in Parliament who were
going to take away the No Deal option
from Boris if they can that then means
they don't have to move at all
because they know Boris then faces the
choice of not being able to leave but
having to extend so the Prime Minister
needs to face this down because if they
wanted withdraw this they're going to
take away one of his most critical tools
which is to go without a deal and the EU
knows this would be enormous ly damaging
and they're in recession many of those
countries but a lot of your colleagues
who were seen as sort of very Savard
brexit ears we know if if the backstop
was to go they'd vote for what was left
in they were in the withdrawal agreement
you're saying that's not good enough
now I read a piece about this and say
Boris Johnson understands fully well
what some of the issues are around the
word oral agreement not just the
backstop at issues around legal control
during the course of the implementation
period issues around defence these are
all part of those discussions and
negotiations I'm one of those that says
I want Boris Johnson to have a free hand
and this to get on with it but I trust
him to know what the problems are and I
trust him to do is level best to get a
reasonable deal from the EU but I
believe the EU will step up to the plate
once they know the alternatives that is
Britain leaves with a deal
that's really interesting a man called
hair out of ink oh I think it is there's
a German MEP said to the Commission it's
your fault do you know when Britain
leaves its like 19 or 20 of the smaller
countries only 27 total leaving at the
same time it will be cataclysmic for the
European Union they know that they're
sitting on a deal that gave them
everything they're not going to suddenly
say I tell you what let's give you back
this stuff
but they will once they realize there's
no other way but leaving without a deal
any but yeah in terms of the of the work
that needs to be put in that I mean
Simon Cove near the the Deputy Prime
Minister in Ireland was saying well look
though part of the problem with this the
whole backs up which just seems to be a
key element of this obviously it's that
no serious alternative has been foot
forward the go through well why I went
to Monsieur Monet twice widowed in
Paterson what is being and with a team
of experts including customs people and
we back in October pointed this out when
the deal hadn't been fully agreed to and
they said to us at the time and an email
exchanges this is probably where we're
going to end up these are all the
alternative arrangements we drafted all
this stuff okay so they heard about this
back in October we offered to work on it
immediately but then the government
caved in and signed this terrible
agreement we went back to see them again
in April to say you know you could still
change this deal and get it through and
the attitude was different because
they've got their deal so mister Kovan
ii and the others are talking nonsense
the reality is that there are other
arrangements I've got another paper
which is about to be given to the
government that shows there are ways to
secure our legal position look
appreciate your forthright views this
morning thank you very much indeed